Greg leaks has died
will you love her yes comfort her I will
honor her I will and keep her forever
Greg was married to reality star NeNe
Leakes and was father to six children
his death follows a multi-year battle
with colon cancer with heavy hearts well
right now we especially praying over
Greg right now as he's battled this
thing that they call cancer increase his
faith Lord be with his wife be with his
sons so that they can keep him supported
in June Nene shared that Greg's cancer
had returned the announcement was
followed by Nene giving this update on
Greg's Health two months later
[Music]
just after sharing that heartbreaking
reveal Nene posted this image to her
Instagram seemingly a reference to
Greg's condition Greg was diagnosed with
stage three colon cancer in 2018. but
the following year Nene announced that
Greg was cancer-free after undergoing
treatment the question I have is
the type of cancer that Greg has the
stage that he's at
is it common that is beatable I would
use chemotherapy at this point to try to
reduce that risk of the cancer coming
back Greg's cancer played out on the
Real Housewives of Atlanta but
you never know what's in you until
you're at that door never thought I had
it in me to fight cancer you have been
my light I couldn't do this without you
I couldn't I wouldn't even try
so I want to thank you baby
in 2019 Nene opened up to E.T about
sharing that Journey on TV what was it
like to get the response from the fans
and the viewers who are maybe going
through the same thing you and Greg and
your family is going well I can say that
I had a lot of fans to reach out to me
caretakers were emailing me left and
right saying we understand what you are
going through now there were people who
did not understand what a caretaker role
is or they just didn't understand me
saying I was frustrated they were like
why are you frustrated you're not the
one with cancer but you know I I was
frustrated because I was a caretaker and
being a caretaker is hard Nene and Greg
first married in 1997 they remained
together until divorcing in 2011.
however the couple reunited and
remarried in 2013. I would just like to
say I love you so much their neptuals
became the center of a TV special titled
I dream of Nene the wedding I want to
toast my groom my love my soulmate the
man of my dreams Mr Brown secondly I
want to thank my wife
[Music]